so here we are on Memorial Day weekend
2020 the quintessential American holiday
which usually signals the start of the
lazy days of summer beach fun and
backyard barbecues the day itself
recognizes the military heroes who gave
their lives so we can live freely and do
these very things we honor them by
observing parades displaying the
American flag visiting cemeteries and
memorials pausing at 3 p.m. to remember
the Fallen and thanking God there were
heroes willing to die for the rest of us
but this Memorial Day is different
America has been brought to her knees by
an invisible enemy instilling fear and
panic we were helpless intentionally
uninformed as we watch this enemy spread
from China to Europe to the United
States we buckled and bowed to unknown
science and to models that were more
wrong than right I'm not criticizing
anyone they were doing their best to
protect us but authoritarian governors
and local officials looking to flex
their pathetic muscles to keep us on
lockdown or another story New York City
and LA are still on lockdown Democrat LA
mayor Garcetti says la will not fully
reopen until there's a vaccine and
schools will probably not reopen until
kids can get tested weakly Democrat
Governor Gavin Gavin Newsom in line with
him and Democrat Governor Andrew Cuomo
never figured out that seniors need to
be isolated and protected and he did
nothing when complaints were made and
people begged that kovat infected
patients not be put into nursing homes
and long-term care facilities where 5800
seniors died
Jarius Republican governor Ron de Santos
in Florida with two million more people
than New York criticized mercilessly by
the left for not doing enough early on
only law
1,000 seniors although one is too many
but he knew to protect and isolate those
seniors all the while Governor Cuomo
spent his time pontificating about New
York's need for ventilators in which in
the end he didn't need a naval ships
which in the end were virtually empty
and the Javits Center returned back from
a hospital to its original Convention
Center Democrat governor Pritzker of
Illinois refuses to protect the
religious freedom of congregants in his
state last Sunday at least three
churches were hit with fines for holding
services in Chicago while liquor stores
marijuana dispensaries and Home Depot
are wide open because they are
considered essential businesses now
Americans instinctively want out of the
chains that lock us in our homes that
force a virtual house arrest upon us
that won't allow us to attend church and
seek to economically punish those of us
who prefer to work for our families in
our future and now more than 600 doctors
have had enough sending a letter to
President Trump calling the widespread
state orders keeping businesses closed
and kids home from school from a mass
casualty incident with exponentially
growing health consequences but then
again I told you this weeks ago for some
there will simply be no business to
rebuild for others there will be no
coming back from the depths of
depression alcohol or drug abuse cancel
the elective surgeries prolonged
enormous physical pain suffering and
further stress and depression for every
percentage drop in employment there are
five to ten thousand deaths occurring
depression suicide domestic violence
child abuse resurgence of alcoholism
drug addiction loss of hope battered
women locked at home with their abusers
abused children not be
identified or protected because they
cannot go to school now even the front
cover of the New York Post read it needs
to end now the Big Apple is dying its
streets are empty tens of thousands have
been plunged into poverty our leaders
have no plans no answers you know New
Yorkers have already learned to socially
distance folks we are past the danger
zone and Americans know it they feel it
and in some states they are willing to
come out and protest the totalitarian
orders of politicians in Michigan
Illinois California and New York and the
question that so many Americans asked
was it necessary for government to
completely shut down in the first place
that question doesn't really need to be
answered now what's done is done but the
question that does need to be answered
now is why any part of America is shut
down we no longer need it we know the
danger we know what to do the elderly
can isolate we've got this
there is no longer justification for
this lock down the curve bended
hospitals are not overwhelmed so what
are we waiting for and don't tell me a
vaccine we don't know when and if that
will happen but the divide is clear the
left seizes on a nanny state
authoritarian approach to keep you
scared home and down and that includes
hiding Joe Biden in the basement as they
gleefully move toward their siren song
of socialism the right wants you to
choose your destiny your path and your
future we don't want to be told how much
we need to live on or how to live we are
a capitalist society we know the dangers
and we know how to live and we will not
allow the left to use this pandemic any
longer to infringe on our constitutional
rights our freedom of speech the right
to exercise our religion and our
the liberties to peacefully address the
wrongs of governments the words of
Ronald Reagan government's first duty is
to protect the people not run their
lives so on this Memorial Day weekend as
we recognize respect and honor those who
died defending these very rights it is
important that we reaffirm our faith in
this nation that it is indeed the home
of the free because of the brave
so as we pledged allegiance to the
American flag we recognize two things
the flag does not fly because the wind
moves it it flies with the last breath
of each soldier who died protecting it
written by a gnome and two that we are
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
and that means deciding how we will live
our lives